[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cinq villages et 5000 personnes peut
être sont engloutis sous cet énorme
fleuve de névez et de roches qui a
descendu entrons les pentes du mont
bhaskaran le plus haut sommet du pérou
sous l'action d'un brusque réchauffement
des températures
l'effroyable avalanche s'écrasa dans le
plus grand fleuve côtier du pays
déclenchant sur le cours inférieur un
raz-de-marée qui balaya la vallée sans
cadavre seulement ont été retrouvés les
autres gisent sous le linceul gris épais
de plusieurs mètres qui couvre une
largeur de 2 km
[Musique]
la ville de bradford en angleterre doit
faire face à une dramatique situation
civils pakistanais ils sont établis
depuis longtemps ce groupe de population
s'accroît au moment de noël de visiteurs
venus directement de leur pays or si les
précautions sanitaires à l'arrivée à
karachi sont draconiennes elle semble
l'être beaucoup moins au départ c'est ce
qui fait qu'un voyageur atteint par la
terrible maladie qui fait chaque année
plus de cent mille victimes aux indes a
pu débarquer et contaminé l'angleterre
depuis les candidats à la vaccination
forment des queues interminables aux
portes des hôpitaux les cliniques et les
pharmacies sont assiégées et on a ouvert
à londres dispensaire spéciale
ses troupes en armes dans les rues de
jakarta où l'on tire appelant
heureusement ne sont que des manoeuvres
que le présidence au carnot en conflit
avec la lande sujet de la nouvelle
guinée faits se déroulaient à
l'intérieur de la capitale dans ce
climat le maréchal égyptien abdel rabb
climat maire est venu lui apporter
l'appui du colonel nasser décidés à ne
pas laisser passer par le canal de suez
les forces ou des renforts néerlandais
ce qui ne va pas manquer de compliquer
la route du porte-avions hollande et
karel doorman qui vient de quitter
rotterdam pour une croisière de trois
mois dans le pacifique
[Musique]
amari 17 plasticage en une seule journée
c'est on l'espère un record qui ne sera
pas battu l'attentât commis au ministère
des affaires étrangères et l'une des
plus dramatiques l'illustration de ce
terrorisme qui horrifie maintenant tous
les français deux morts plusieurs
blessés graves des dégâts importants
des mesures sévères ont été prises
contre cette vague d'attentats
chaque nuit maintenant la police procède
au contrôle des voitures en circulation
contrôle sévère et qui en concordance
avec le renforcement des surveillances
et l'aggravation des répressions devra
réduire les possibilités des plastiques
heures
et un [ __ ] bientôt lincendie de gassi
touil au fond du sahara des bulldozer
déblayent les ferrailles et les débris
de toutes sortes éjecté du puits par
l'explosion
des pompes géantes ont pompé à 800
mètres de profondeur des milliers de
mètres cubes d'eau stockées aujourd'hui
dans deux réservoirs en matière
plastique de 5000 mètres cubes chacun
puis à l'aide de bulldozer à cabine
blindés munis de crochets géant on
ramènera les ferrailles l'incandescente
qui encombrent les abords du puits
restera alors à souffler à l'aide de
l'explosif le plus puissant la flamme de
300 mètres qui consomment des fortunes
et illumine le désert
[Musique]
pour percer les secrets de l'univers
l'homme a besoin d'instruments toujours
plus puissants toujours plus précis et
le radiotélescope de jaude râle banque
en angleterre vient d'être dépassée par
les installations de l'observatoire de
paris annonce est annoncé on s'était
borné jusqu'ici à l'étude des éruptions
solaires les batteries de
radiotélescopes en écoutait les
palpitations
[Musique]
désormais on veut aller aux limites de
l'univers et pour ça on à renoncer aux
systèmes de jor-el banques qui n'ont de
précision annonce est un miroir plan
mobile un miroir concave fixe un
récepteur les radios source reçu par le
miroir mobiles sont réfléchis sur le
miroir fixe qu'il est concentré et les
renvoie sur le récepteur
[Musique]
le miroir mobile un rideau de maille
métallique long de 40 mètres et qui
achevait en mesurera 90 des moteurs
l'orienta volonté
[Musique]
lui faisant face le miroir fils un autre
réseau de maille métallique de 35 mètres
de haut et de 65 de large en attendant
d'en mesurer 300 solidement ancrées dans
le sol et rendu parfaitement rigide par
une armature de soutènement sa surface
con carne a pour rôle de concentrer les
ondes en un faisceau de cap m de
diamètre dirigé sur l'antenne de
réception
est le résultat de tout ceci
ce sont ces enregistrements d'apparence
anodine d'apparence seulement car ils
révéleront par exemple une collision de
galaxies l'agonie de milliards de
systèmes solaires et de leur planète la
formation d'une nébuleuse ou telle
anomalie de la nébuleuse d'andromède que
la lumière mais sans milan a traversée
de bout en bout
avec cet appareil l'homme atteindra des
distances de 7,8 milliards
d'années-lumière qu'aucun télescopes ne
peut atteindre sur ces graphiques il
lira l'histoire fantastique des mondes
qui naissent ou qui meurent aux limites
de l'univers si l'univers a des limites
[Musique]
canaveral c'était la répétition générale
première américain premier au voyage
autour de la terre le colonel glen à
repasser son rôle et quels rôles dans
tous les détails il a d'abord essayé son
habitacle dans la capsule mercury cet
habitacle dont il disait quand on y est
enfermé on a l'impression de n'être
qu'une pièce supplémentaire la plus
importante naturellement
il était avec les techniciens de la nasa
à l'arrivée de l'avion cargo qui amenait
monstre enfanter un monstre la fusée
atlas
un jour sans doute de tels préparatifs
d'un vol n'auront plus rien pour nous
étonner et seront devenus spectacle
banal mais reconnaissons qu'il ya
aujourd'hui dans ce déploiement de
machinerie de quoi nous laisser rêveur
la capsule mercury et est maintenant
mise en place au sommet de la fusée
atlas il ne restait plus qu'une scène à
jouer du premier acte la scène du départ
[Musique]
le camion ou glenn s'étaient préparés
arrivé sur l'air de lancement un terrien
en descendait comme diraient les
martiales
[Musique]
john glenn comme alan shepard et virgil
grissom prenait l'ascenseur pour gagner
l'habitacle dans lequel il était entendu
qu'il ferait bientôt une fois deux fois
ou trois fois le tour de la tête
et la dernière scène sachez par la
répétition du décompte fatidique des
minutes 1 600 vols les terriens junglen
était prêt
[Musique]
à
et route des français et de tous les
favoris en général dans la descente du
hahnenkamm à kitzbühel en autriche le
vainqueur le suisse vif horaires
personne ne l'attendait
pourtant depuis quelques années foreurs
est l'un des meilleurs descendeurs du
monde et sa victoire dans la descente du
hahnenkamm n'est sans doute pas dû au
hasard mais à sa grande maîtrise
c'est avec aisance et sang froid qu'il
triomphe de toutes les difficultés à
plus de 100 à l'heure comme guy périllat
l'an dernier
[Musique]
une fiche de consolation pour les
français la très bonne performance de la
classe biberon du ski féminin
marielle goitschel qui est encore à
l'âge où l'on joue à la poupée se joue
des difficultés du slalom féminin de
badgad stein avec la dextérité d'une
grande championne
[Musique]
elle est déjà une grande championne en
moins d'une saison elle est devenu le
chef de file du ski féminin français
sa seconde place à badgad stein devant
les meilleure skieuse du monde le prouve
amplement
ip riga après son très mauvais
classement dans la descente de
kitzbuehel avait une revanche à prendre
dans le sla
[Musique]
apprenant des risques qui en donnait des
frissons aux spectateurs il a bien
failli retrouver une première place à
laquelle ils s'étaient habitués depuis
l'an dernier
seulement là encore personne n'avait
pensé aux outsider et périllat s'était
coiffée sur le poteau par ferries un
américain presque inconnu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]